well this morning we are looking at some
ways that you can be more
environmentally conscious and it starts
out with something so easy for cycling
it is pretty easy and apparently uh
Heather it's something that southern
Nevada does pretty well we're told that
90 percent of us do have access to
recycling and that's a lot more than
other parts of the country so Candace
Charles is live at the Republic Services
recycling place up at Cheyenne and
commerce tell us how it works and it
looks like you're gloved up and ready to
go
good morning folks yes recycling is
actually our last live in events and
helping to make our planet green we have
to reduce and reuse first three hours
you guys can remember now I'm on the
line here and this is the recycling
point the Sorting outboard as you can
see this is something that can be
recycled but you can see it's pretty
heavy because there's stuff still in it
so people can't recycle this there's
everything here from corn Jeremy Walters
and Republic Services that's a big bear
bear is a Louis Vuitton bag really
how can people help sorting out these
things to make it easier not only for
the valley but our planet so we need to
focus on the fundamental recyclables
right the bottles cans jugs paper
cardboard when we're throwing in things
that don't belong we're doing more harm
than good and especially if things still
have food or liquid in them they can
contaminate good recyclables we don't
want good things going to the landfill
and if we can't sort them properly
that's unfortunately what's happening so
be the most impactful recycler you can
and focus on the good recyclables and
the good recyclables only all right and
we will have a list of those as well
some helpful tips for you on our website
newsnow.com Jeremy is just pulling it
all out right now as you can see there's
so many different things here we're just
getting starting and showing you the
process here these hard workers are
sorting all of this right now coming up
I'm going to show you a little bit more
about what this all turns out to be but
for now our life for a public services
I'm Candace Charles a news now it is
crazy this stuff that you guys are
pulling out of out of the line there's
crazy now at the same time tomorrow UNLV
Community Partners are hosting a
recycling event at the Thomas and mac
and there you can load electronic waste
unload electronic waste paint paper
files this runs from nine until noon
again this is tomorrow at the Thomas and
Mack